you look back at your actions albeit on
set or in personal life and go you know
what I was immature and stupid and oh
yeah I I really wish I wouldn't acted
that way and I I wish I could apologize
to that person now yeah and I and I
think especially with with this podcast
being toward like mental health in the
best way of
self-reflection being able to learn from
those things like there there was a time
they were directing an episode of
Smallville outside in the parking lot
and I was trying to finish a an episode
I was directing and starring in in the
basement of the Production Studio and we
were trying to do this 300 sort of thing
like a like a slow bullet going and
Clark does this and
outside they kept calling on the radio
that they had problems with problems and
I it was like three or we had to stop
when they were rolling and back and
forth and I lost I lost my composure and
I went went out there and I raised my
voice toward a crew who I know I know
all their
names and the first D comes over and
says Tom Tom Tom I need you to and I'm
like I'm not gonna calm down it was just
this so such an immature situation right
and he goes and he I don't remember what
he said but he said something that shut
me up like he probably said shut the
[__] up and he pointed up in the sky and
there was a a like a crane with a light
with a 5k or two up there and it was
moving like 10 feet he's like we're
trying to get that guy down and I'm
telling you dude I've never felt this
since or before this
complete like I am so out of line right
now embarrassed or unin and uninformed
and embarrassed and everyone's like
that's okay you didn't know you didn't
have the information and this and that
that that experience has helped me now
as I deal with set situations or life
situations going on where you remind
yourself hopefully that you may be
triggered but maybe the next trigger is
to remind yourself you might not have
all the information for the situation it
might not be about you it's about
something
else even better yeah yeah and then I
never did it again by the way I never
rais my voice upet ever again yeah when
you when you watch that video of
Christian Bale and he's just losing his
[__] and going nuts do you are are you
were you shocked could you ever did you
do you ever think you could do something
like that I'm glad you brought that up
because that's what I did it's a that's
a that's what I did in the story just so
before I think you and I talked about
this and it was like oh that's so
everybody was like it's so horrible he
did that I'm like they call it
stacking in in Psychology it's a it's a
stacking of this emotion that adds to
the explosion you're stacking up the
dynamite and then it explodes right I'm
I don't know Christian Bale I don't
knowbody there there's been some behinde
scenes things which helped me believe
what I what I'd like to think which is
he's been dealing with this he's asked
for changes it hasn't been changed I
don't agree with how he dealt with it
but when it happened I was like well
there's other actors I mean there's wae
Phoenix had a very famous
intimate why they leak this information
is
actually kind of horrible to me I think
it I think it's a good thing because if
you leak that sort of information I mean
look there should be privacy and no one
should have that but like somebody was
like you know the guy who grabs the the
tape or the film and takes and gets a
transfer he's like you know what I'm
gonna take a copy of this and no one's
going to know it was me and I'm gonna
air it because this guy's a [__]
[__] now I think he's a brilliant
actor Christian Bale I I don't know the
details but I bet it helped him I bet
bet he'll never do that again I bet I
agree if if something is presented to
you where you see yourself in another
light and you don't like it that's when
you make a change when you hit rock
bottom is the only time that you realize
your uh you know your issues your um
what's the word your uh your freaking um
personality your the way you handle
things affects other people and there
consequences I think when you see that
you you that's the best chance you have
to make changes I I have a friend of
mine who and I I'm not gonna say his
name because he's too F he's literally
too famous to mention and years 30 years
ago he did a film with a very famous
director and I'm sorry to be that guy
who's not naming names but here's the
situation his director called him in and
said I need you to watch dieses and he
walked in and he's watching the dailies
and he's seeing himself on camera
literally chewing his own mouth off
because he'd been doing cocaine oh wow
and the director was like I want you to
see this
and the story was told to me as a as a
as a coming to Jesus moment for him and
he goes That's when I stopped doing
cocaine so it speaks to what you said
when he saw
himself he was like I I can't be that
person anymore we
justify what we are feeling in any given
moment but when you're being
photographed and then that's why when
like you're doing something is when goes
let me video it you're like whoa who
whoa whoa who you know like there is a
thing about that but if we
were maybe that'd be helpful I don't
know